ein dunkles geheimnis im herzen europas
die anlage war teil von etwas sehr
großem und sehr gefährlich
[Musik]
im nordwesten der usa spuren einer
industriellen revolution vorangetrieben
vom pionieren und pilgern
ein jahr nach dem technologischen
durchbruch kam es zur katastrophe
eine geisterstadt in südafrika vom
goldfieber heimgesucht da ging etwas
schief und zwar sehr schnell
und rätselhafte bauwerke in england
ist eine verbindung aber welche
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
im nordwesten polens rund 150 kilometer
vor der deutschen grenze steht ein
komplex aus verlassenen gebäuden
wir sind in europa im ländlichen polen
umgeben von wunderschönen kiefern
letztlich kommt etwas unerwartetes in
den blick etwas das von menschen gebaut
und versteckt wurde
das ist kein gewöhnlicher wald darin
verbirgt sich eine alte gut geschützte
und weitläufige anlage
es ist als wäre man in einer
dystopischen hobby dorf gestolpert die
eingänge liegen unterirdisch und führen
in eine versteckte welt
der geheimnisvolle komplex tauchte lange
zeit auf keiner landkarte auf die frage
ist warum
jemand hat etwas sehr mächtiges gebaut
und es dann mit erde bedeckt um es vor
einer gefahr zu schützen
überall sind gitter und luftschlitze die
auf ein belüftungssystem hinweisen
wer hat diese anlagen errichtet und was
verbirgt sich in ihrem inneren
[Musik]
der unterirdische ort war von anfang an
streng geheim
der polnische archäologen jackowski
asche system rätsel seit jahren auf der
spur
ab 1990 begann die polnische
öffentlichkeit sich für diese städte zu
interessieren
ich war der erste der hier
archäologische untersuchungen vornahm
laut kürzlich freigegebene dokumente
beginnen die bauarbeiten im jahr
damals trennte der eiserne vorhang ost
und westeuropa
die politische lage ist angespannt
im kalten krieg fürchtete die
sowjetunion dass der westen jederzeit
von europa aus angreifen könnte
der potenziellen bedrohung sitzt die
sowjetunion stellungen in den
ostblockstaaten entgegen
die polnische armee hatte keine andere
wahl als die vorgaben der sowjetunion
umzusetzen dabei wussten die polnischen
soldaten nicht einmal genau was sie da
überhaupt bauten sie glaubten es wäre
ein kommunikationszentrum
die vorstellung einer sowjetischen
kommunikationsbasis in polen ergab sich
eine gute tarnung
aus sicherheitsgründen hatte jedes team
nur zugang zu einem begrenzten areal so
konnten sie sich keine vorstellung von
der größe der anlage machen
dies ist der bunker von cottbus co
teil eines riesigen netzwerks aus
unterirdischen militärischen
einrichtungen
im ernstfall hätte der welt von hier aus
größte gefahr gedroht
der code name der anlage lautete 3001
wir stehen hier direkt neben dem
monolith bunker die türen mussten wegen
dem was da drin vor sich ging immer
geschlossen bleiben
wenn man sieht wie groß das tor ist kann
man erahnen wie groß der bunker sein
muss
im inneren offenbart sich die wahre
bestimmung der einrichtung
ein blick genügt um zu erkennen dass
hier etwas hochempfindliches gelagert
wurde
da sind barrieren versiegelte bereiche
in die nichts hinein ausdehnen vor allem
aber nichts herauskam
wenn man eins und eins zusammenzählt
kommt man schnell auf radioaktives
material
die anlage wurde sehr wahrscheinlich
gebaut um dort taktische atomwaffen zu
lagern
sowjetische jagdbomber hätten die sie im
krieg 2 gegen nato-truppen einsetzen
können
in den 60er jahren erkennen die russen
dass die reichweite ihrer raketen im
angriffsfall nicht ausreichen würde
sie beschließen deshalb atomsprengköpfe
in den satelliten staaten zu deponieren
niemand sollte die standorte kennen
nicht einmal die polnische bevölkerung
also errichtete man sorgfältig geplante
streng geheime bunker
in ganz polen entstehen mehrere
munitionslager für atomsprengköpfe
30 mal stärker als die bomben von
hiroshima und nagasaki
[Musik]
aus taktischen gründen hielten die
sowjets das ganze geheim
sie haben damals abgestritten dass sie
nuklearwaffen in polen stationiert
hatten
mehr als 20 jahre lang hält die
sowjetunion die polnische bevölkerung im
dunkeln über die gefahr die dort unter
der erde liegt noch heute deuten spuren
auf das tödliche potenzial des arsenals
hin
[Musik]
wir stehen hier in der haupthalle von
hier aus wurden die sprengköpfe bewegt
in den räumen ihr rechts wurden sie
gelagert
druck messgeräte und sensoren belegen
dass bestimmte lagerbedingungen penibel
eingehalten werden mussten
plutonium für die militärische nutzung
rostet leicht deshalb gab es
luftentfeuchter und ein hygrometer um
den wassergehalt in der luft zu messen
moderne atomwaffen sind hochsensibel
wenn etwas schief geht kann das leicht
zur katastrophe führen
deshalb müssen temperatur und
feuchtigkeit ständig kontrolliert werden
besonders wenn sich alles um geheimen
abspielen soll
es scheint allerdings als habe die rote
armee ihre spuren nicht gründlich genug
verwischt
ende 1969 wurde die anlage
fertiggestellt und übergeben
sowjetische soldaten begannen sofort mit
der planung machten dabei aber fehler
sie pflanzten fichten rund um die anlage
in
dem wald dort stehen aber größtenteils
bilden
wenn im herbst die blätter abfallen
bleiben nur schmale weiße stämme und das
laub am boden übrig
[Musik]
während des kalten kriegs überwachten
die amerikaner die sowjets mit
satelliten sie suchten dabei nach
ungewöhnlichen aktivitäten
die amerikaner ließen sich von den
pflichten nicht täuschen sie wussten
genau was vor sich ging
berichten zufolge identifizieren die
geheimdienste damals 23 ähnliche anlagen
die über den ganzen ostblock verteilt
sind
dieses wissen nützt ihnen jedoch wenig
im ernstfall könnte westeuropa gegen die
sowjetischen raketen kaum etwas
ausrichten
vielen ländern würde die totale
vernichtung droht
[Musik]
im kriegsfall hätten die soldaten die
sprengköpfe auf lkw geladen und dann in
den bunkern auf weitere befehle gewartet
20 jahre vergehen in denen die welt
mehrmals an der schwelle zum atomkrieg
steht
erst als der eiserne vorhang fällt
entspannt sich die lage
[Musik]
1991 zogen die sowjetischen truppen ab
und übergaben die anlage offiziell an
die polnische marine
nach dem abzug der roten armee kommt die
wahrheit über den bunker von pop bosco
ans licht
als der kalte krieg endete hat sich die
sowjetunion verpflichtet einige ihrer
anlagen für inspektionen zu öffnen
im zuge dessen musste sie einräumen dass
sie atomwaffen in polen stationiert
hatte
viele der nun leerstehenden bunkern
werden geplündert und zerstört
einer wird in ein gefängnis umgewandelt
die anlage in pop ostchor jedoch
erinnert bis heute an eine zeit in der
die welt am rande eines nuklearen
infernos stand
durch diese gänge zu laufen ist wie eine
zeitreise
jedes mal wenn ich durch die tür in
diesem bunker komme habe ich das gefühl
die russen wären gerade erst abgezogen
an einem fluss im nordwesten der usa um
20 kilometer südlich von portland oregon
steht eine reihe von industriebrachen
industriehallen schornsteine hier muss
früher eine menge los gewesen sein
das ganze wirkt wie die leere hülle
einer industrieanlage die fenster sind
zerbrochen es regnet rein
wie in einer geisterstadt
die verlassenen gebäude stammen aus
verschiedenen zeiten offenbar hat sich
hier im laufe der jahre viel verändert
in der mitte stehen ältere ruinen die
nicht zum rest zu passen scheinen dieser
ort muss jahrhundertelang genutzt worden
sein aber nicht immer zum selben zweck
er war früher richtig was los maschinen
unter volldampf jede menge arbeit
wie hängt all das zusammen und was
steckt hinter dem wandel der sich hier
verzogen hat
die nähe zum wasser scheint ein
wichtiger faktor gewesen zu sein einige
gebäude sehen allerdings so aus als habe
genau dieses wasser sie auf dem gewissen
was auch immer da vor sich ging der
fluss ist der schlüssel dazu
[Musik]
über 150 jahre schlägt hier das
industrielle herz von morgan city
mehr als einmal muss sich der ort dabei
den entwicklungen der zeit anpassen
eine spektakuläre konstante bleibt dabei
jedoch immer erhalten
wir sehen hier den zweitgrößten
wasserfall der usa gemessen am
durchfluss eine gigantische
energiequelle
die eu notfalls in klecken moskau
georgen schon die pioniere des wilden
westens machen sich ihre rohe kraft zu
nutze
doch wozu denen all diese kuriosen
gebäude
sie sind produktionsstätten für ein
material das uns bis heute bestens
vertraut ist papier
als der bedarf an papier wuchs wurde die
region dank ihres großen waldbestand zu
einem zentrum der zeitungsproduktion
lange zeit beliefert die riesige
papierfabrik die westküste der usa
darunter auch die zeitung los angeles
times
der lokalhistoriker dawns gott kennt die
geschichte der anlage
das ist maschinenhalle nummer vier hier
wurde das papier hergestellt
früher herrschte hier reges treiben
die produktion lief rund um die uhr
zuletzt war es eine papierfabrik aber
davor diente der ort ganz anderen
zwecken
unter den rostenden ruinen verbergen
sich die überreste einer früheren ehe
diese steinblöcke bilden die grundmauern
man sieht nur noch einen kleinen teil
vom ursprünglichen gebäude seine
geschichte reicht zurück bis ins jahr
davor haben die ersten menschen die von
der kraft des wassers angezogen wurden
bereits seit jahrtausenden hier gelebt
die amerikanischen ureinwohner wussten
den wasserfall zu nutzen dank des
steilen gefälle sammelten sich die
fische in einem natürlichen becken das
war wie eine art speisekammer
die ureinwohner lebten seit generationen
im einklang mit der natur das änderte
sich als die weißen siedler eintrafen
mitte des 19 jahrhunderts lassen sich
pioniere in der region nieder die das
ende des organträgers markiert es zieht
sie in eine siedlung gegründet von john
mclaughlin der als vater von oregon
bekannt wird
mclaughlin erkannte das wahre potenzial
des wasserfalls
das war der startschuss für die
industrialisierung in der gegend die von
da aus schnell voran schritt
die villa mit falls haben eine
unglaubliche energie die tosende kraft
des wassers spürt man sogar von hier aus
wir stehen quasi im sprühregen sehr
beeindruckend
[Musik]
dies ist das sägewerk an den villa mit
fords bei seiner eröffnung ist es die
erste einrichtung die die kraft des
wasserfalls kommerziell nutzt das werk
begründet ein weitläufiges
industriegebiet das schon bald entlang
des ufers entstehen soll es dauert nicht
lange bis mail und wollen den betrieb
aufnehmen und der standort sich zu einem
florierenden
produktionszentrum entwickelt
die dinge entwickelten sich nach und
nach der ort wuchs alles begann am
westufer und mit der zeit wurde auch die
andere seite erschlossen
schließlich kommt eine anlage hinzu die
das leben in der region vollends
umkrempeln wird
gegen ende des 19 jahrhunderts hatten
sich verschiedene branchen angesiedelt
ihm stand ein radikaler umbruch bevor
etwas das ich auf die ganzen usa
auswirken sollte
bröckelnde betonblöcke und rostige rohre
geben hinweise auf die damaligen
pionierleistungen
es wurde ein kraftwerk gebaut um die
wasserströmung zu nutzen
hier war früher die station a
da unten kam das wasser raus nachdem es
die turbinen passiert hatte mit denen
der strom erzeugt wurde
strom mit wasserkraft zu erzeugen ist
damals keine neuheit mehr
was also ist das bahnbrechende an diesem
kraftwerk
das potenzial ist enorm
hunderte tonnen wasser pro minute
und dann kamen die menschen vor 100
jahren daher und wollten diese unbändige
kraft nutzen es war gefährlich wie
sollten sie das anstellen
ende des 19 jahrhunderts erzeugen
menschen bereits strom mit wasserkraft
die meisten häuser in den vereinigten
staaten werden aber noch mit kerzen und
gas beleuchtet denn es fehlt eine
methode energie über längere strecken zu
übertragen bei den lila mit fords
gelingt dieser entscheidende fortschritt
vom kraftwerk aus verliefen
kupferleitungen 20 kilometer entfernte
portland ein historischer moment die
erste stromübertragung über eine große
entfernung in den usa
das war der durchbruch schlagartig war
portland eine moderne stadt
nur wenige monate später kommt es jedoch
zu einem verheerenden rückschlag
kaum ein jahr nach dem technologischen
durchbruch schlug das schicksal zu ein
sturm führte zu hochwasser dass fast
alle gebäude zerstört
die sturmflut von 1890 hat die
ursprünglichen anlagen einfach
weggespült
das ist das risiko wenn du dich mit den
naturgewalten einlässt wenn etwas schief
geht dann richtig
die menschen müssen am boden zerstört
gewesen sein kaum hatten sie es
geschafft elektrizität über eine längere
distanz zu übertragen weil das kraftwerk
hinüber
kurze zeit nach dem sturm beginnt der
wiederaufbau
und schon wenig später treibt das
kraftwerk die industrialisierung weiter
voran
eine florierende papierbranche entsteht
die anlagen gehören zu den ersten ihrer
art die mit elektrisch betriebenen
maschinen arbeitet
nach und nach weichen die älteren bauten
modernen produktionsstätten
ihre überreste säumen heute das ufer
in den besten zeiten sind hier 2000
arbeiter beschäftigt
aber papier herzustellen hat auch seinen
preis
die damals entstanden bei der
papierproduktion diverse umweltgifte die
bis ende der 60er jahren leider auch im
fluss landeten und einen großteil der
fischpopulation töteten
die fabriken bekommen das problem zwar
in den griff dennoch werden sie von den
entwicklungen der zeit überholt
[Musik]
steigende kosten strengere umweltgesetze
und die günstige konkurrenz aus dem
ausland führten am ende dazu dass die
papierfabrik schließen musste
[Musik]
dieser ort steht stellvertretend für die
geschichte von ganz amerika von den
ureinwohnern über die ersten weißen
siedler bis heute
[Musik]
relikte aus über 200 jahren industrielle
entwicklung zeugen von stetem wandel und
schon bald soll hier neu und umgebaut
werden um das gelände für die zukunft zu
erschließen hier ist noch lange nicht
schluss
[Musik]
menschen haben diesen ort stets für das
genutzt was ihnen zu der zeit bedeutsam
erschien heute wird der wasserfall vor
allem wegen seiner schönheit geschätzt
[Musik]
in einem tal in der südafrikanischen
provinz mpumalanga
liegt eine siedlung mit einer bewegten
geschichte
man erkennt auf den ersten blick dass
sie verlassen ist aber es ist nicht die
typische kleine post statt die man
draußen im hinterland erwartet eine
hauptstraße führt hindurch es gibt
hotels kirchen und zwar viele der ort
ist ganz schön groß
die gegend ist total abgelegen die
menschen müssen also einen triftigen
grund gehabt haben diese hügel zu
besiedeln
hoch oben auf dem kamm stehen mehrere
gebäude deren baustil sich vom rest
unterscheidet
liefern sie hinweise warum sich die
menschen hier niedergelassen haben
die verlassenen häuser und maschinen
deuten ziemlich sicher darauf hin dass
es hier früher industrie gab aber was
verarbeitet oder produziert wurde ist
weniger klar
den hügeln gab es sogar eine bahnanlage
also musste auch etwas gewesen sein dass
man damit transportieren wollte
um welches transportgut handelte es sich
und was hatte es mit den häusern am fuß
des hangs zu tun
[Musik]
das muss eine boomtown gewesen sein aber
dann ging plötzlich irgendetwas schief
hat ein dramatisches ereignis die stadt
auf dem gewissen wieso ist da niemand
mehr
[Musik]
die landschaft ist atemberaubend schön
trotzdem bleibt die frage warum sollte
sich jemand mitten im nirgendwo
niederlassen
ende des 19 jahrhunderts ist der
landstrich ein magnet für abenteurer und
entdecker ein unerschlossenes terrain
auf dem bald ein neuartiges fieber
grassieren wird
[Musik]
in südafrika des 19 jahrhunderts drehte
sich alles um ausbeutung und schnelles
geld obwohl sich dieser ort quasi am
ende der welt befand strömten die
menschen zu tausenden von überall her
dorthin
was lockte die menschen her und warum
gingen sie dann wieder
die antwort liegt auf dem grund der
bäche und flüsse
auf den ersten blick liefert die
landschaft keinerlei hinweise auf die
reichhaltigen bodenschätze
man muss schon danach suchen
1886 zieht es viele glücksritter nach
afrika es ist der auftakt zu einem der
größten raubzüge in der geschichte
rund zehn jahre zuvor hat südafrika
seinen ersten gold rausch erlebt um die
entdeckung des edelmetalls ranken sich
bis heute legenden
1873 gab es einen goldsucher der als
robert patterson bekannt wurde weil er
seine gesamte ausrüstung
1500 kilometer in einer schubkarre
transportiert hatte
die nachricht ging um die welt und bald
strömten viele andere goldsucher in die
region
quasi über nacht entsteht ein
provisorisches lager
josef meschik kennt die geschichte des
bergbaus in der gegend
als die ersten goldsucher hier ankamen
gab es noch keine häuser sie schliefen
in zelten
nach wenigen monaten schürfen 1500 gold
hungrige an rund 4000 stellen allesamt
auf der suche nach dem wertvollen
edelmetall
bald darauf lösen häuser mit
wellblechdächern die zeltstadt ab
an diesem ort nahm der südafrikanische
gold rausch seinen anfang
[Musik]
dies ist die geisterstadt pilgrims rest
sie ist umgeben von flussläufen die
reiche beute versprachen
pilgrims rest wurde schnell zu einer
klassischen boomtown die bevölkerung
explodierte es gab so lorenz und alles
was junge männer mit zu viel geld in den
taschen sonst noch braucht
in weniger als zehn jahren dürfen sie
gold im wert von heute umgerechnet
mehreren hundert millionen euro
am anfang gab es weder maschinen noch
chemikalien die menschen wissen dass
gold nur mit wasser aus
eine klassische methode der goldsucher
war das schürfen in flüssen dort findet
man partikel die sich infolge der
erosion ablagern
man spricht von sogenannten schwimm gold
also gold das aus den erzeugern in den
bergen ausgewaschen wurde
einige goldsucher werden unvorstellbar
reich aber das abenteuer birgt auch
schattenseiten
[Musik]
jeder goldrausch zog auch rücksichtslose
typen an sie setzten alles auf eine
karte und nahmen vieles auf sich um
schnell reich zu werden
die leute waren wie elektrisiert aber
viele verzweifelten auch wenn ihre suche
erfolglos blieb
das reichte bis zum selbstmord so
verrückt waren die zeiten damals
das war ein hartes leben die meisten
gaben ihr geld für alkohol aus nur fünf
prozent wurden reich der rest blieb arm
hinzu kommt dass es in südafrika
politisch brodelt
pilgrims rest wird in einem blutigen
konflikt verwickelt der tausende das
leben kostet
der zweite burenkrieg brachte die
goldförderung imperiums rest weitgehend
zum erliegen
1899 beginnt der zweite burenkrieg in
dem das britische empire und die buren
republiken oranje freistaat und tanz
wahl einander gegenüberstehen die
holland ständigen bohren kämpfen für
ihre unabhängigkeit vom britischen
kolonialreich
nach anfänglichen erfolgen geraten sie
gegen die militärisch überlegenen briten
ins hintertreffen was die buren jetzt
brauchen ist das gold aus pilgrims rest
sie übernahmen die region viele der
goldsucher mussten das weite suchen
die buren armee will mit dem gold den
dringend benötigten nachschub bezahlen
eilig errichten die buren eine
provisorische prägeanstalt und legen
eine goldmünze auf den sogenannten welt
kommt von dem nur 530 stück hergestellt
werden aber bevor er zum einsatz kommt
müssen die buren sich ergeben
das war erst der anfang
davon macht er sich niemand eine
vorstellung
die gier nach gold treibt die
technologische entwicklung voran zwar
liegen die produktivsten tage der mine
damals noch in der zukunft doch so
mancher traum ist längst unter trümmern
begraben
einige goldsucher taten sich zusammen
und professionalisierten ihre
unternehmung
die zeiten von hacke und schaufel waren
allmählich vorbei
das erklärt die großen maschinen und die
steinbreche anlagen
um all diese geräte zu betreiben
brauchte man elektrische energie
die lösung war das wasserkraftwerk
belvedere das bis dahin größte
wasserkraftwerk auf der südhalbkugel
wir sind hier am grund des breit river
canyon wo das wasserkraftwerk belvedere
steht hier gab es schon strom als man in
england und frankreich noch überwiegend
gas verwendete
die gewaltige anlage produziert über
2.000 kilowattstunden
dank der zuverlässigen stromversorgung
kann die mine einen gang höher schalten
jetzt begannen die wirklich goldenen
zeiten die grubenbahn brachte einen
zusätzlichen schub
plötzlich konnte man riesige mengen
eisenerz transportieren und mit ihnen
das darin enthaltene gold
mine die hoch zeit dauerte von 1913 bis
die menschen dort produzierten
112.000 unzen gold und machten einen
gewinn von
550.000 rand das mag unspektakulär
klingen aber damals war es eine menge
der industrielle bergbau bringt großen
reichtum zugleich beschleunigt er den
niedergang von pilgrims rest
als das land seiner schätze beraubt ist
geht die goldproduktion zurück und die
menschen verlassen die stadt
bis in die siebzigerjahre schleppte sich
das ganze noch dahin dann wurde die mine
geschlossen trotzdem ist die stadt nicht
von der bildfläche verschwunden
[Musik]
1986 wird der verwaiste ort zum
nationaldenkmal erklärt
eine mit gold erbaute südafrikanische
boomtown bewahrt für zukünftige
generationen
die menschen lieben solche abenteuer
geschichten die vorstellung von einer
boomtown von goldsuchern und der damit
verbundenen romantik ein bisschen davon
findet man noch heute in krems rest
[Musik]
im südwesten englands in der grafschaft
somerset liegen zwischen sanft
geschwungenen hügeln und grünen weiden
relikte aus einer vergangenen zeit
da sind wir also in dieser wunderschönen
englischen landschaft weit und breit nur
felder dort sieht es so aus als hätte
sich nie etwas verändert
dann fällt einem plötzlich eine markante
baumreihe auf und dahinter ein
wasserlauf und ein tunnel deren einen
hügel hineinführt
tunnel ist gesperrt man kommt nicht
hinein und kann auch nicht erkennen wie
es drinnen aussieht
was macht dieser tonne hier und wo führt
er hin
in der umgebung gibt es noch weitere
bauwerke
und weit dieses mysteriösen tunnels
stehen noch einige andere ziemlich
eigenartige dinge
für eingebettet ins unterholz verbergen
sich schwere klobiger betonklötze sie
wurden gezielt dort platziert und
stechen komplett aus der umgebung heraus
sie scheinen aus einer anderen zeit zu
stammen als der turm
wir haben also zum einen diesen tunnel
und zum anderen die deutlich jüngeren
betonbauten es gibt eine verbindung
zwischen ihnen aber welche
die rätselhaften relikte in der
ländlichen idylle von somerset haben
etwas mit dem tödlichsten konflikt in
der geschichte zu tun
und mit einer revolution die die welt
verändert hat
ein teil der bauwerke stammt aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert zu derzeit
steckt großbritannien mitten in der
industriellen revolution
das 19 jahrhundert war eine epoche
ungeahnter möglichkeiten die industrie
löste die landwirtschaft als wichtigsten
wirtschaftszweig ab der viel geld
versprach
der bedarf an ressourcen war riesig und
wuchs mit jedem tag dabei waren nicht
nur die mengen entscheidend sondern auch
wie schnell sie verfügbar waren
die lösung ist ein netz aus kanälen dass
die großen flüsse miteinander verbindet
[Musik]
das kanalsystem brachte großbritannien
einen gewaltigen schub
plötzlich war es möglich große mengen
quer durchs land und in die ganze welt
zu transportieren
bis anfang des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
bauarbeiter fast 3000 kilometer
wasserstraße lokal historiker david
wyler kennt die geschichte der anlagen
wir sind hier an einem ort namens
crimson hill ungefähr auf halber strecke
des kanals der die orte krieg und chart
verband ein sehr unwegsames gelände
aus der luft erkennt man dass der kanal
einer baumreihe folgt da ist es ziemlich
flach aber dann ist da plötzlich dieser
hügel ein echtes hindernis
es gab keinen einfachen weg drumherum
also mussten sie mitten durch auch wenn
das einen preis hatte
dies ist der crimson hill kanaltunnel
jetzt kommen wir an den eingang ich bin
das erste mal hier das ist also ziemlich
aufregend das gitter soll eindringlinge
abhalten dann schließen wir mal auf die
bauarbeiten an dem 20 kilometer langen
kanal beginnen 1835
der gut anderthalb kilometer lange
tunnel ist dabei die größte
herausforderung
sie gruben von der spitze des hügels
nach unten und dann zu beiden seiten
nach außen damit fingen sie an denn wenn
das nicht funktioniert hätte wäre das
ganze projekt gescheitert
[Musik]
jetzt packen wir durch den crimson
tunnel keine ahnung wann hier zuletzt
jemand war normalerweise ist der herr
abgesperrt er ist in wirklich gutem
zustand nur hier und da dringt etwas
wasser 1
aber noch bevor der kanal fertig wird
setzt sich eine erfindung durch die
englands wasserwegen konkurrenz macht
der chart kanal war von anfang an dem
nachteil er wurde erst gegen ende der
kanal periode gebaut in den 1840 an
setzte sich dann die eisenbahn durch die
war schneller und konnte viel mehr
fracht befördern
mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts gibt
es bereits rund 10.000 kilometer
schienenwege das land ist besser
erschlossen als je zuvor die
dampflokomotiven sind nicht nur
schneller sondern auch kostengünstiger
die hochzeit der kanäle ist vorbei
in die kanäle konnten einfach nicht
mithalten es war billiger schienen zu
verlegen als wasserstraßen auszuheben
nach gut 20 jahren im betrieb wird der
chart kanal stillgelegt aber
das ist noch lange nicht das ende der
geschichte
nun war die gegend wieder vor allem
landwirtschaftlich geprägt die
betonbauten entlang der wasserlinie
zeigen aber dass danach noch etwas
anderes passiert sein muss
70 jahre nachdem der letzte last kann
seine waren transportiert hat kommt der
kanal im zweiten weltkrieg noch einmal
zum einsatz
nach der evakuierung aus den kirchen
mussten sich die briten auf die
möglichkeit einer deutschen invasion
einstellen
also bauten sie verteidigungsanlagen
und zwar nicht nur an der küste sondern
auch in somerset
wie aus dem nichts taucht diese
betonkonstruktion auf 1 bill box bunker
aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
da drüben ist noch einer zusammen
konnten die soldaten darin die feier
linie in zwei richtungen kontrollieren
die bürger gehören zur turnten stopp
einer 80 kilometer langen
verteidigungslinie zwischen bristol und
dem ärmelkanal
im falle einer deutschen invasion soll
sie den vormarsch der truppen abbremsen
beim bau haben die briten natürliche
hindernisse so gut wie möglich mit
einbezogen also flüsse wasserstraßen
bahndämme alles was als hindernis taugte
in wenigen monaten entstehen 18.000
solcher pill box bunker und ein weise
panzersperren an strategisch wichtigen
positionen
sie sollen bei der verteidigung des
südwest korridors helfen
doch zum glück werden sie nie gebraucht
die briten haben diese befestigungen
schnell und mit begrenzten ressourcen
auf die beine gestellt im ernstfall
hätten sie die wehrmacht aber kaum
aufgehalten für die soldaten in so einer
box wäre das wohl ihr letztes gefecht
gewesen
[Musik]
1945 ist die wehrmacht besiegt und die
gefahr einer invasion vor über die
tonkens topline bleibt sich selbst
überlassen und verfällt
die anlagen waren schon damals nicht auf
dem neuesten stand der technik aber sie
ließen sich schnell und kostengünstig
bauen und gaben der bevölkerung ein
gefühl von sicherheit
bis heute erinnern die überreste des
verteidigungssystems an großbritanniens
erbitterten kampf gegen die tyrannei
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
vom erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]